we got another story i want to jump to
nearly a third of republicans still
believe trump will be reinstated this
year in paul released two days before
conspiracy theorists predicted it would
happen yeah i can i can hear your
reaction uh
they believe that i think in in what but
in four days
was it the 15th no no okay i'll say i
guess that it's the 13th i don't know
when they think trump is going to be
brought back but why i'll put it this
way man
all of these claims
require tremendous leaps of faith about
what's happening with the with the
government
and even if you believed everything
all the impropriety and all the all the
accusations and all the conspiracies
you would have to then believe that
there is an element of the government
that is going to remove the current
administration
to allow a path for trump to come back
and be reinstated and somehow and i'm
just thinking like
to get from point a to z to where where
everyone is at with this reinstatement
thing it's like from going from a to z
like you got to go a b c d you got to go
each and every step and that is such a
tremendous leap i just don't understand
how people can believe that's going to
happen i mean it's it's it's scary um
and
i think the people who are promulgating
that are really either completely
out of their depth right and that's the
most generous interpretation of it the
other one is really malicious where it's
just like they're lying they're grifting
right they're they're lying um to
persuade people to continue to give them
money i'll tell you this is possible
that donald trump be is bro is
reinstated as president oh it's
physically possible yes absolutely it's
in the realm of this existence it's not
like i'm saying he's gonna grow wings
and fly to the moon or anything like
that but it's just like i would rather
buy a lottery ticket you know like the
likelihood is just astronomical i
i'm a bit
i suppose the right word would be
flabbergasted by people who would be
willing to believe
something so
i what tremendous
could and would occur because the amount
of things that would have to happen for
that for that process to play out is
astronomical
astronomical yeah you could prove that
he cheated you could prove that biden
knowingly cheated right
and the thing is like it would be like
the democrats thinking that they could
prove you're saying hypothetically
hypothetically right yes because
otherwise it sounds like you're saying
no no no no i am saying the hypothetical
world you know the hypothetical world
where even this that that biden would be
impeached over this stuff is a
hypothetical where biden literally knew
about everything i mean it's a
preposterous measure again
i do not believe that it's hypothetical
um but even if you got there like it
would be equivalent to democrats in 2016
saying if well if we prove trump won the
elect like colluded with russia to win
the election then hillary will be
president right and you'd be like
exactly
you know you know what you know you
don't you know blew my mind because i
was watching the symposium and they play
this video cause i'm i'm not somebody
who's gonna be like i won't watch that
no i watched i've watched a lot of it i
can't obviously can't watch all because
i'm working but what they claim that uh
nasa's involved with like elements in
china and the deep state and stuff and
i'm like okay okay slow down there
you cannot open your presentation by
telling regular people who don't know
what's going on that nasa is involved in
some kind of a plot
because you you you lose people man you
just it's i'm sorry it's out there it's
it's absolutely they didn't they did
they mean the nsa i'm trying to figure
out a way to interpret that generously
nasa the the the poorly funded
organization aeronautical and space that
literally had to give up the space
shuttle because they didn't understand
everybody knows that nasa's actually
uh the illuminati
right well they decided to actually stop
going to space and start like secretly
plotting coups against the elected
government i should mention i was
curious about this number that you
brought up that a third of republicans
believe that trump will be reign stated
this year so i just went and took a look
at the data that they pulled this from
so the question they asked was how
likely do you think it is that former
president donald trump will be
reinstated
as u.s president this year if at all and
out of 2000 people surveyed
i think the percentage was 10 percent
saying
very likely nine percent saying somewhat
likely and then 13 saying not very
likely than not very likely at all or
don't know or no opinion so it's it's
not that a third believe he will be it's
that they that a total of a third lean
towards maybe yeah or that is possible
because yeah because not very likely
doesn't sound like that person is saying
i think trump is going to be reinstated
within this year but what's what's so
there's people think 10 says very likely
and then what's the next percentage let
me pull this back up um i i just lost
this my apologies ten percent of
republicans or ten percent of the public
oh yeah actually let me double check
because this so this all right so
actually the survey it looks as if the
survey is only surveying republicans but
let me take a moment and i'll clarify
this too because this was a garbage
headline from daily mail they go on to
say 29 of republicans believe trump
could be reinstated now actually
that's actually i that's correct
yeah trump could be reinstated in the
abstract following the sort of path i
laid out where he becomes a speaker yeah
isn't the right word no no no could
trump be reinstated no well no no no
that reins
it is physically possible in this world
for a rube goldberg like like political
operation to occur in which trump
becomes speaker because nancy steps down
and then there's a snap emergency
election where they're like we're gonna
vote for trump and some for some reason
progressives protest and say we'll vote
for trump too it will never happen but
the point i'm making is that it might be
a point zero zero zero zero zero zero to
do one chance it could happen right so
it's it's depending on how you you play
the semantics of the yeah i was saying
like
saying that it would be it wouldn't be a
reinstatement in that case it would be
like he would be that this
speaker of the house that then is
elevated yeah he was he succeeded to the
president the succession would he be
then succeeded again succeeded but but i
just want yeah i know i i got it i want
everybody uh listening to just imagine
something right now okay just imagine
this first i want to say i do not
believe uh i genuinely mean this i have
looked at a lot of the anomalies a lot
of data i believe there should be an
investigation i believe there should be
audits i think we need that to build
confidence back for the american people
and to and to help kind of resolve this
extreme divide
but i want you to imagine something
it's it's august 14th the cyber
symposium has ended
at the very end of the symposium mike
lindell stands up without saying a word
and presses enter on a keyboard
and documents appear on the screen and
all the journalists in attendance are
like
i can't believe it i work for the new
york times and even i must admit it's
true and then they write fervently like
wow mike lindell oh he's correct and
then all these things
and then all of a sudden biden is like
seen in a plane and he's flying to china
and kamala harris is like crossing the
border canada and they're like what do
we do and then the secret service picks
up trump and they drive the white
that's not going to happen no it's not
going to happen no it's not you know i'm
not that's not ever going to happen it
sounds like a cool movie it'd be really
cool yeah it would be a great movie
different we've changed the names uh it
seems like no one would know who it was
about right
i don't like joe biden okay gas prices
are going up joe biden comes out and
says he issues a warning on gas prices
it's his fault gas prices are going up
and the media's covering for him saying
it's not his fault i just want to make
sure everybody understands i don't like
that guy okay yeah did we talk about
today how he decided his administration
requested that opec release more oil
like
we have oil in this country we had a
pipeline that was going to be built
that was under construction with lots of
jobs already on the line let's let's get
into that who shut that down
probably the same guy who rigged the
machines it seems like the minions
getting out ahead on this one because
they know i can't say for sure but the
fact that they did stuff in secret it's
a canadian corporation that at this
corporation right it's canadian it's one
of what i've learned it's canadian um
and they don't want to
get busted they don't want to get
attacked for it so they're going on the
offensive that's what it sounds like is
that does that make any sense to you i
mean i think it i don't i don't think
that's it at all i think it's as simple
as their billion dollar business has
been decim is decimated by what a lot of
people said about them because think
about it from the perspective of if
you're offering election machines you
need to have a completely un besmirched
reputation otherwise no one can hire you
even if that's a good point you know if
other people are saying things about
your machines that are false if if half
the country believes them then your
business is dead which means that what
you know all the things that were said
about dominion crush their business in a
way that caused them
hundreds of likely hundreds of millions
of dollars in damages i'll tell you this
first and foremost i said we gotta have
open source either they free the code
like ian often says this is the one area
where i agree because we need to be able
to see what those machine machines do
like flat out my friend told me a story
i think
my friend told me a story about some guy
who got a speeding ticket from a radar
gun yeah and when he went to court
they said you know we've got the
evidence that shows you were speeding
and then he requested the court uh
subpoena the source code for the radar
gun and he said to the judge for all we
know it's a random number generator and
the judge agreed the the the people who
make the radar gun need to prove
that their gun works this way and how
and show the code to the defense so the
defense can understand the evidence
presented against him i think that if
we're gonna have elections
we gotta have
the ability to look at the code that
being said
based on everything that's happened the
accusations made against dominion i
think dominion should be purged from
every single uh uh voting system every
county
just because for one reason
half the people in this country
are skeptical are concerned are scared
have lost confidence now that is in line
with defamation that that that's bad for
dominion across the board i i'm looking
at this way
i want america to get better i want
people to come together i want to get
back to having policy arguments not
tribalist arguments and that means
there's got to be compromise and if
you've got the trump supporters saying
we do not trust this company then we say
we'll hire a different company we'll
make the source code open source or
we'll make it open source i totally
agree right elections people need to
have public faith in elections and and
know one company's fate or like business
success comes up over that at the same
time like if that company was lied about
in a way that caused them this damage
and made it so we nobody could use them
for an election rigging machine then
they have a legit defamation claim but
are they against the people who lied
about them look michael and dell's not a
poor guy and i think they're swinging
like a billion dollars but they're
they're whether they're squeezing blood
out of turnip you know what i mean like
they might get something but i mean
they're also going after all the news
companies too right they're suing fox
news newsmax oan i mean there's fox says
i mean that's where i think they're
thinking the big money is but
you know they're going to go after
everybody you know what's crazy is first
i'm going to say this too like i don't
like dominion voting systems i don't
like i'm learning about proprietary code
in our public elections i am not a fan
of that that's bad
as a company i don't know uh i will say
that they're both based in canada and
colorado so i don't know if they're if
you can call them just a canadian
company or whatever
but
i don't know man no you have to you have
to free the software code because it
could you don't know that it's doing
anything nefarious but they could have
like secret backdoor
things that say if this vote tallies
this then flip to this i mean and you
just don't know that's the problem it's
it's right right right it's not even
about
saying that we believe there's a grand
conspiracy and this company's evolved
it's about saying we want to make sure
your code works properly yes and that
in matters of public election we can see
how we need transparency in government
yeah it's a good way to put it i
recognize there's confidential there's
secret there's top secret and stuff we
get it there's classified information
but when it comes to our elections we
should be able to look at the code and
be like oh yeah i said i get it
we don't need classified information and
about how our elections work exactly
that's actually completely antithetical
to what elections are designed to do
which is make people they're the entire
point of having elections is to make the
losing side agree that they lost right
yeah right that's very true that's like
that's that's so that we have peaceful
transitions of power right and and and
the problem i have right now with i
think that's going on with like arizona
and wisconsin stuff is that you know
they're issuing subpoenas in arizona and
they're actually getting pushback it's
like just
handed hand it over like look i get it
they they you know they're arguing it's
a waste of time or whatever it's a
violation of security and i'm like dude
you need to convince people that you're
claiming lost that they lost
you should with a smile on your face be
like here's the data man have that have
a good day
yeah or we just change we change the way
our elections are run to make it so it
it should be
it should be to a point where it's
stupid to even consider that the
elections are fraudulent like if you if
you were in israel and you were like oh
that election was was rigged
every israeli would just laugh at you be
like it's just not possible like you
can't the way that the the measures we
have in place for election integrity
like what you have to do to be able to
vote what you have to do to verify that
vote the custody of the ballots like
it's so
but you mean that literally like
israel's system is israel's system is
secure super secure right like they
don't use electronic they don't machine
that's right
like we we don't need to use them like
that said not using them will be bad for
all these companies businesses but we
don't need to use them that's one of the
things one of the one of the guys that
the symposium said we got to vote amish
no electricity yeah i don't necessarily
agree with that either because if you
hand someone a stack of papers and then
you trust them to go count it yeah they
don't have to they can count it any way
they want so i would imagine a number of
different people verifying that they
counted it properly but i agree right
that there's an advantage of the
computer technology where you can have
all of the data stored perpetually for
everyone to look at whenever they want
in public on a blockchain or just for
you to verify with like with like a qr
code that only your account can scan and
read to verify that your vote is being
tallied as you said it and then it's
kind of up to you to verify your own
vote but at least there's a public
available database where you can do that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you